if your friends do not make you feel
good they are not your friends attention
is the number one
asset hello and great day everyone my
name is Jared um pleasure to be in your
presence um thank you jar glad to have
you in mine as well how you guys do up
there I have one question for you
um being financially wealthy yes does
that bring you Joy or does it just make
you happy
neither Jared I promise you and I I know
most people a lot of people struggle
with my point of view on this real
talk I and I'm incredibly aware of some
of the stresses money takes off the
table
but the amount of people that have money
that I know that are incredibly unhappy
deeply
insecure deeply in depression is so much
you couldn't even imagine money
accelerates one's
truth if you're happy you're
happier but if you're angry you're more
Angry money exposes us it doesn't change
[Applause]
us thank you my
guy all right hi everyone my name is
Michael mcferson I'm an alumni here from
my Country Day 2019 uh 2019
yeah
just want to express my gratitude uh
country day was an amazing place to grow
up I was here from kindergarten all the
way until I graduated and uh it's
definitely more than a school it's a
village a community so just want to
express my gr clap that
up so my question for you Gary is are
you familiar with the law of diminishing
returns graph yep okay great so for
anyone who isn't it's basically the
notion where you know you have one dut
two Donuts it's great by the time you
get to 10 Donuts you're probably not
feeling too well so what point Gary does
that graph start to go down for you in
any of your decisions motives business
ideas where do you start to say okay any
further investment is not going to bring
a return but rather the opposite effect
I only know it when it starts to
happen right I have no idea that's the
coolest part of like being a human I
have no clue what I'm very good at is
when it happens I adjust my life what
I'm incredibly strong of at and I feel
comfortable saying this I think I stink
at most things like every other person
bless you but I think but I
think maybe one of my greatest core
strengths is being able to make hard
decisions when I'm no longer happy and I
fight for that it's something I think
about every day and so for me it was
really easy because I'm only talking to
you about emotional things the law of
the diminishing returns were never real
for me on physical things I don't want
anything I don't need stuff I don't want
stuff I want to feel and so usually for
me it's you know going through a journey
I'll give you a good
example for the first 10 12 years of my
growth as a public figure when I would
walk through an airport I would look at
every single person dead in their face
with the hopes that they knew who I was
so we could
talk
now because of hitting enough of a level
of that and it wasn't so much that I
needed it for my ego though I always try
to ask myself that it goes back to what
I said earlier I just really enjoy
interacting with people I like it so
much but I equally like my alone time
and so what ended up happening was
walking through an airport used to be
100%
alone now that it could be predominantly
taken up by people saying hello wanting
to P pitch me their business or tell me
a story or take a photo
now I'm valuing having a little balance
of my own time during that time to catch
up on work or family or whatever I'm
doing so I don't look at every person in
the face anymore when I'm at the airport
I noticed that today even right and so I
adjusted there was a point two years ago
three years ago where I just changed and
so the answer is I'm not sure brother
but what I would tell everybody is I
don't sit on it the way most normal
people do and I say normal people like
I'm I'm just so this goes back to
gratitude I'm not sure how I got that
DNA I don't know like I don't know what
happened but I don't I don't tend to sit
in a place of unhappiness very long I
can't function there I really can't
that's what led to my weakness of cander
I don't like
negativity right and so I uh I don't
know but I also know that the second I
start feeling it if it sits for a
sustained period of time I'm not
knee-jerk I can deal with inconvenience
or even dealing with a difficult
situation but I will not dwell in it I
think one thing my parents definitely
taught me that I highly recommend
everyone is we need to stop complaining
so much I think I think that was that's
huge for me because I think one of the
reasons I act a lot and fix is cuz I
don't know how to really complain like I
don't really like the concept I also
think the people that listen to you
complaining are just either enablers or
other people that like to complain so
they're waiting for their
turn and so I think we need more
accountability and I'm incredibly
accountable if I am unhappy I don't
think it's the president's fault I don't
think it's my parents fault I don't
think it's anyone's fault but myself and
I'm in control and so I act on it that's
the insight
there thank
[Applause]
you hi uh I'm Nick I'm a freshman at a
high school up in boa
and know I still don't know what I want
to be when I grow up and I know you
always say oh you're still very young
but how old are you 14 years old you're
not even young you're not even born
yet um
yeah go ahead brother uh I don't know
what I want to be so should I look for
it or should it come to me what should I
do well let's talk about it in a
different way so why do you want to
know what you're going to be so I can
care for it you know maybe like study
for it yeah I mean definitely don't
study for
it um I mean that in a in a really
important way meaning of course you need
to know it you
know sorry Neema
trying what the [__] did you think was
going to happen up here
um not all studying is bad by by the way
to his let me explain what I mean by
that actually to his point I study 24/7
I will tonight after I've dinner with my
parents lay in their apartment from 11:
or 12 whenever we're done to one I will
spend at least an hour studying what's
happening in popular
culture I study I study so much it's
scary by the way while I was getting D's
and Fs I was studying I memorized the
price of every baseball card in the
world I'm being dead serious I by the
time I was in high school I read the
wine spectator cover to cover and was
studying to understand every wine what
wines I've been studying I only study
it's but where I'm going with this my
man is I just want to make sure that a
couple things happen first I promise you
that everyone in this room that's 35
years and older wishes they enjoyed
their childhood a little more a little
more fun a little more playing couple
more times to hang out we were also
focused on where we were going we
weren't able to fully maximize what we
were in you're 14 years old like you
have your actually actually especially
with I don't know if anybody's paying
attention to modern medicine this dude's
going to live for 130 more years like
actually this dude's going to be 150
years old one day on Earth still so bro
You' got a lot of time and so here's
what I will say and this is actually a
lot of fun cuz this actually goes for
all the 40 and 50 year olds in the crowd
as well who think they've wrapped up
back to modern medicine and the fact
that the far majority as I look around
here pretty much the majority of this
room isn't at halftime in their lives I
would I would tell you to get really
focused on something called curiosity if
I could give you one good piece of
advice the biggest mistake that kids
make in high school is they're worried
about high school social dynamics and so
they don't go do things that they want
to do or learn about because it might
not be cool or their friend group might
not be about it so if you're into
theater or if you're into science or
robotics or comedy or I have no idea
what's running through your mind that
catches your eye on YouTube or Tik Tok
or things of that nature but the way
you're going to find what you should do
in life in the best way the way the
people that are the happiest that what
they do is you got to go try it you like
comedy go try to do a standup set
somewhere you know what I mean like go
try stuff cuz you don't know if you love
it until you try it I think of life the
way I think about food watch this kid
how many people here do not like oysters
raise your hand it's okay just raise it
high raise it higher please for the
little guy
okay of those people keep your hands up
do not like oysters don't lie how many
have never had
one that's life brother that is the
thing I am most interested in what I
just showed you in real life a lot of
people make decisions without ever
trying Isn't that cool never stop
curious It's curiosity like you you just
don't know you don't know unless you try
like you just don't know and we don't
try enough stuff all of us try more
stuff sorry hi Gary um thank you for
being you so inspirational thank you
what's your name my name is Jen abot and
I'm luxury real estate agent and I just
sold to the most famous soccer player in
the world and you went to SAI Arabia and
sold to
[Applause]
Ronaldo
the most popular
socer um I'm curious like how do I ride
that wave with being respectful to to
the celebrity and keeping it classy yeah
that's a by the way that's a tremendous
question I mean I think first respect
comes in
asking right and the truth is it's
probably there's a potential aspect
where it's even awkward to ask
right look I think some things do a
little bit better in a B2B environment
than a b Toc environment I think
one-on-one with people in this room in
your circles in the small scene that is
super luxury real estate in this town I
think people know and there's an
opportunity for you to feel comfortable
in closed environments to talk about the
truth I think starting to put it on
blast publicly which would lead to a lot
more awareness I'm aware may start to
cross that Chasm that may be a little
you
know more of a disrespectful move and I
think you know back to who we're
referencing that's such a one of one
like that that's a small group of people
so you know for me I think it's about
permission you know so I think if you
want to go there and you have the
strength to ask that question if it
would be okay to you know respectfully
and lightly reference it I think that's
a question you can ask and because the
worst that can happen is no reply or a
no I think if you don't want to go there
my personal point of view but this is a
subjective opinion is it's better for
smaller groups behind the scenes and the
good news is you know this in the game
that you're playing you it's not about
reaching the masses most people can't
afford what you're selling and so the
behind the scen stuff I think can be
effective thank you you're
[Applause]
welcome Victoria um I just wanted to ask
what do you think is like the key to
being individual when it comes to
entrepreneurship so you and your
business stands out more than the rest
the M by spending 100% of your time on
the customer and spending almost no time
paying attention to your
competitors oh you guys like that
one I think I think it's fun to have my
dad here because this was a very big
thing that I was passionate about
naturally in my teenage years you know I
would tell my dad like I was a very
unusual kid in that like I was obsessed
with business and I would talk me my dad
and mom lived about 45 minutes away from
my dad's store and so we had a long
drives both to and from the store and
you know I talked a lot in those drives
and my dad would listen and we would
talk and I remember being passionate
with my dad in my teenage years and in
my early 20s of like it doesn't matter
what our competition does it really
doesn't like as long as we focus on the
consumer and I think I've always
innovated because and and Avery and Nick
who are with me on my journey in Vayner
X
like they are probably laughing inside I
can't even name most of the companies
that Vayner X and Vayner media compete
with I definitely can't name the CEOs of
my compe like it's just irrelevant and
so what I think happens when you just
focus on the customer actually like no
[__] like focused 100% energy on the
customer you end up innovating cuz
you're so close to to the customer you
have a pulse of what they want now not
what worked for someone else
yesterday thank you're
welcome G thanks for spending some time
with us man
so
GCE I consumed your first piece of
content I think like 8 n years ago you w
a hoodie being in college oh I remember
and then it's ironic you're also here in
an academic setting so the same one here
but you know throughout Years also
contined to content on social media I've
always been curious to ask you this
question which is you've maintained
relevance for seven eight years which is
quite difficult to do especially in
social media you talk about practice and
being close to your customer you just
spoke about uh hustle and how you
changed your definition of that word how
do you act what's the actual practice
for you look like what does that
studying actually look like because on
social media within that domain it's so
difficult with the barrage of
information that's coming out of you
right like you're reading comments or
you're talking people on the street how
do you make the decision to say hustle
is not the right word to continue
hitting the right message with my
audience so so with the hustle thing or
where I'm at now which is different than
the reason I'm going to answer this
twice is I'm about to give you advice
I'm about to give you insight to someone
who has a large audience and I'm aware
that most people don't today it's easy
you know when I said tonight I'll spend
an hour I will now I may go into
trending topics and read a drillion
different like news outlets and look at
my stream and see if there's anything
happening or I might just spend which
happens way more often the entire hour
reading all my
DMs and in the DMS is where I got the in
by the way I had no feelings towards
eighth place trophies nine years ago I
really was indifferent genuinely I
didn't think like I just didn't think it
was a big deal until I read a million
comments from 22 and 23 and 24 year olds
and got more insight to why so many
people are so scared to fail and started
to backtrack and have conversations so
today my friend to answer your question
it's because unlike the far majority of
my contemporaries who are fortunate of
and earned enormously large audiences
I've doubled down on being close to them
instead of the
reverse you know most of the people that
have made it from a following
standpoint either gave up on reading the
comments when it got too much
or never really did it in the first
place for me it's how I got there the by
the way a lot of people don't know this
the real way the Gary B thing happened
was when Twitter came out in two and
like started really hitting in 2007 I
spent 10 hours a day on it talking to
people every day I actually spent four
years straight not going to sleep until
I reped to every tweet and every email I
got from 2007 to
2011 so I I got here this way and so now
it's easy for me to keep a pulse on it
cuz it's coming to me for everyone who's
trying to build it I still think the way
to do it is to join into the
conversation
meaning I think too many people think
they need to consume it without
participating so going on X Twitter
going into a Instagram post where
there's content and then replying to
three or four people that are replying
to it I don't think we Network or engage
or conversate enough and now it's
incredibly impossible because Politics
on both sides of the aisle both sell
fear in different form and now
everyone's scared to talk to everyone
because everything next year is going to
be a mess because everyone's going to be
on tilt because it's a presidential
election and nobody wants to deal with
all that negativity you feel like you
not even sure you could say anything and
it becomes something that people want to
fight about and so it's really
unfortunate I have uh I've heard you
talk about auditing your close like
friend group right your circle as you
grow these circles change what's your
advice on staying authentic with those
that you truly connect with even though
you might be out growing of them by by
just reallocation you know a lot of
people here so what he's referring to is
I talk a lot about like and I was just
touching on a little bit like here's my
punchline I think people spend way too
much time on negativity I don't know to
really tell you and so there's a lot of
people unhappy because you consume
unhappy things the news and you hang
around unhappy people relatives that are
unhappy
and I don't think you should cut out and
no longer talk to your homies you know
like I hate when people hear it and
think they've outgrown their friends and
they want to get bougie that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying pay attention to
everybody you spend time with and what
you consume and you you know like that
whole saying when we were growing up
like you become who you hang out with
like it's just super real like whatever
you're consuming is what's dictating
your point of view and so I think the
way you do that because I I believe in
ly loyalty so much I'm incredibly loyal
to my friends I'm still in touch with
everybody I've ever grown up with but my
allocation of time with them may be
different than it was when I was best
friends with them when I was 10 or 20
and so I would tell you you don't have
to cut people out of your life but you
need to communicate to them why you're
limiting your time with them and by the
way that may Inspire them to look inside
and pay attention to what they're
thinking
about
thank you for coming um I have two
questions what's your name brother cam
cam it's so nice to meet you thank you
nice to meet you
too call me
car how do you study Trends and the
second question is what do you think the
new generation should start investing in
and
how
so the way I study Trends is that I
think people have a very very very
distorted view of social media so social
media in my opinion are empty pipes that
people fill with information not the
government not though they're allowed
not the you know some Lords behind not
the
Illuminati
us and I think what social media has
done extremely well in the last 5 years
seven years is not change us I think
it's exposed us and I don't think people
like what they see but if you're like me
you love what you see I consume
unlimited amounts of social media
personally not when I'm doing my
professional work which I'll answer in a
minute and I see nothing but happiness
because I choose to follow people that
are optimistic and practical and trying
to provide good and I think everyone
here if I asked you to think of three
very good people you can do it the
question is why don't you spend more
time with those people and less with the
ones that are not as good that becomes
the interest question so how do I study
Trends I consume Facebook Twitter
Snapchat Instagram and all the platforms
as they pop up and I watch what people
are talking about and what they consume
I go to Google Trends it's free so if
something catches my eye I then go to
Google Trends I look at how many people
are searching it I put in the work
that's how I do it as far as what I
think you should invest in the answer to
that question my man is
self-esteem instead of crypto or real
estate or cannabis or trading cards or
something like that definitely don't do
cannabis at this age
um I think the biggest thing that will
have an impact on you being able to
achieve what you want is you need to
start right now which is what every
person in this Auditorium wish they did
at your age you need to start in
realizing the most important truth in
the world which is you need to figure
out how to start loving yourself
yesterday you need to figure out
my man the world is going to be very
good at telling you what you're not good
at what you need to focus on is
realizing that you're good at plenty of
things you might have not found them all
but that you're a good person and you
have good intent and we you really have
to work on that and I promise you
especially at the age you're at right
now pay attention to the friends that
you hang out with you need to figure out
if they make feel good and if they don't
even if they're the most popular or the
coolest you need to cut them out if your
friends do not make you feel good they
are not your
[Applause]
friends can I can I speak one more is
that okay of course okay go ahead
brother go fast hi G thank you for
coming uh my name is valer kuk uh I'm a
I'm an alumni from
2017 and I really wish that people like
you would come visit us more often uh
when I was back in high school but I'm
very glad that my co day is giving me
this opportunity for a future generation
how old are you brother uh 24 you're
young enough I know you're good good
that we're here now go ahead my question
is about networking networking um I my
current dream is to go back to Ukraine
after the war and be part of uh
rebuilding the the country's economy
that's awesome and uh I really want to
go into Venture Capital field okay uh I
currently do not have any real Network
in America because I was I came back I
came back to uh America after BL word
again and I'm trying to expend my
network at the moment uh and I've been
trying to do cold calling emailing uh
LinkedIn messages but I haven't been
really getting a lot of replies uh I was
wondering if you have any advice to what
could be I have a huge advice so the the
issue with cold calling and cold
emailing and Linkedin is
and by the way I'm I'm a fan of it but
the problem is you're
asking right it's this is a very simple
game out here it's a game of someone
asks and then then there's the other
person on the other side of it and the
other person on the other side of it
depending on how often they get asked
and depending on how they see the world
the likelihood of them reciprocating is
quite low so I'm a big believer of not
being in a position where you're asking
and don't have the leverage I believe in
the reverse which is why I'm so
passionate about content on the internet
you want to be inventure capitalist okay
I understand theoretically why but the
question is do you have anything to
provide in value right and so I believe
the answer is yes to everyone but I
think you need to put that out there
here's what I mean if I'm you I'm
putting out content on LinkedIn about
your point of view on how to invest in
startups what you see in startups what
you see in small businesses I would do
history work and look at the two three
four five most recent examples of
countries that are in postwar
environments and how that ecosystem was
built to build it back up right what
happened in the former Yugoslavia after
what happened in the mid 90s and make
content around your pattern recognition
that you saw what happened in Serbia and
Croatia postwar and how that worked over
a 25 year window and how you see that
playing out in the Ukraine I promise you
that if you had a thoughtful strategy
like I just articulated to you like I
just talked about the former Yugoslavia
that you would catch people's attention
if you posted 20 30 40 50 times not to
mention you'd have something to put in
your email when you're cold calling
right and you're cold emailing so for
everyone in this
room I'm stunned by how many people
leave it to chance
and luck and a referral the reality is
the ultimate referral right now is the
ability to post content anywhere for
free it's free LinkedIn doesn't charge
you to
post and get people to see it so if I'm
you I go heavy on the attack and don't
be scared because the issue is everyone
thinks they have to be an
expert you just have to be an Enthusiast
let me say this slow cuz this is huge
most of you were not posting about
something like this that you want
because you realize internally you're
not educated or you don't have strength
in it that's irrelevant meaning it would
be wonderful if you did it's a it's
definitely good but if you have the
humility to communicate from a point of
view of enthusiasm or subjective point
of view or hypothesis we've just taken
so many words out everyone thinks they
have to be an expert or a guru that's
silly as a when I started my business
Journey it was these are the things I
felt naturally are they right and over
time that built and so you can go with
like look here's my truth I'm from this
place here's what I sense and by the way
a lot of people will value that from
being from that part of the world there
are tons of American businessmen and
women who know that they don't have the
context of the area but might see the
opportunity and may need a liaison or a
decoder or a translator so you don't
have to act or fake the funk you just
need to tell your truth of what you see
and what you know about your people and
I think you need to post that otherwise
you're reaching out to people that get
do you how many cold emails I get a day
I have three full-time employees just to
delete
them and I'm weird and answer some of
them and I like it so you know I think
the reality is you have to put yourself
in a position the way when I research
tonight I may hit up a random kid in
Alberta because I like what she or h
said about something I'm paying
attention to put yourself in a position
for them to come to you instead of
asking them than you got
it all right one last one last we're
never going home go ahead so as a
current High School what's your name my
name's LCA Bonito I'm a 10th grader at
this school awesome so as a current high
school student it seems everyone's
telling me college is becoming more and
more important you know we Mr not to
call him out but
he really emphasizes how important
college is and my parents are too and
after hearing that you were successful
person I got D's and Fs in school but
still was able to come out of school get
a job and become successful I'm
wondering do you think today where it's
even more competitive and harder to get
a job without a college degree how
important do you think it is today to do
well in school and go to a good college
I think it's a very individual Journey
you know when I was in 10th Grade I was
selling an ungodly amount of wine and
baseball cards and making money are you
doing that right so we're
different and so I think the thing
that's dangerous about anything by the
way there's unlimited people who got
straight A in their life and are
dramatically more successful to me and
then obviously the theme of tonight I
think people are picking up on it I'm
not even worried about the successful
part financially I'm desperately
petrified that most people don't
understand how to become successfully
emotionally right I promise at the end
of the day your parents as you get older
will be much happier that you're happy
versus how much income you make I
promise parents get caught up in the
game especially in incredible
institutions like this I'm empathetic to
it but you know I think parents need to
spend more time looking at people 20 or
30 years older than them and realize
that there's unlimited parents right now
and they're 70s and 80s who are
devastated that their children are
unhappy but they happen to be great
lawyers in doctors and successful
businessmen and women so brother I
promise you both your parents and this
incredible institution will be okay
whether you get straight A's or B's or
C's or that I think the bigger question
is do you know yourself you know I think
like there's unlimited people who are
successful and happy that got straight
A's and there's unlimited people who are
successful and happy who got D's and Fs
the question is who are you which
version of the game are you what do you
like who do you want to be and I think
that's what you need to focus on cuz
that's going to lead to much better
outcomes for the next 100 Years of your
life than whether you get A's or FS I
[Applause]
promise